welcome back to the rockstars i'm eric
voss and the mandalorian season 2
trailer has dropped and whatever else we
were doing we noped out of faster than
baby oda out of a bar fight
i got reacted to this glorious teaser
with the proper amount of spit take but
now there is so much hidden in these
visuals that i gotta break this down
frame by frame
along with a lot of audio clues hidden
in the music and the sound design
i'm gonna cover all of it spoiler
warning in case i dig up too much
let's get started
wow okay so mando's razor crest soars
over this planet toward a destination
moon in its orbit that surface of the
larger planet is
amazingly rendered very similar to the
images of jupiter taken by the juno
spacecraft some are suggesting this
gas giant could be the gas giant yevin
and that moon yavin iv home of the rebel
base in a new hope just because
you know that moon rising over the gas
planet horizon matches kind of the
visuals of yavin 4 lumen into view
though i should say you haven't had a
much more red-ish color to it
others say that destination planet could
be the ice planet shown later but in
those shots the razer crest looks okay
but
here the razor crest is toast the engine
is puking sparks the back
hanger bay door is open like my car when
the trunk won't latch
lost a lot of kidnapped former new
rockstars hosts that way i'm thinking
this leads to the
fiery crash landing that we see later in
this trailer but there's a lot more here
we gotta move on
show me the one whose safety deemed such
destruction
you must reunite it with its own kind
so composer ludwig joranson is once
again doing some interesting stuff with
the music in my reaction video i
wondered if these deep
bass notes could be a didgeridoo was a
didgeridoo
but there's actually an even deeper star
wars reference going on here
i'm pretty sure these are the vocals
from the who not the who but the who
the mongolian heavy metal band that
recorded the song cal was listening to
at the beginning of jedi fallen orders
listen i don't want to upset your rhythm
cow if these are the same guys i love
that giranton is working them back into
star wars now the voice of the
mandalorian armorer from the season one
finale returns reminding us of the
mission she put mando on after giving
him
that new mud orange sigil he now brings
the child to this lamp-lit
town on a new planet earlier this year i
speculated that season 2 might visit
lothal
homeworld of ezra bridger from rebels
rosario dawson will be joining the
mandalorian as a live-action former jedi
ahsoka tano
and chronologically we last saw ahsoka
in the final scene of rebels joining
mandalorian revolutionary sabine wren
in search of the missing ezra with
lothal his home being a very possible
location we're talking about lothal
because it's an extremely important
location of the star wars universe it's
a mining planet producing the mineral
dunium which was used in construction of
imperial star destroyers and the death
star
it's also the setting of a buried jedi
temple that
contained wall art depicting a yoda
figure leading many of us to believe
that lothal might be
the key to secrets about the yoda
species which is now mando's main
mission the town architecture here looks
industrial as if used for mining with
street lamps necessary for miners
working early or late hours
the walls are covered in signs and
graffiti
which is kind of similar to the surfaces
of lothal buildings and rebels more on
those later to the left
creepily a pair of jawa eyes eliminate
watching him from the shadows i don't
like the cigarette beach lurker for my
story of when i almost got murdered
let's move on where this you must
determine
[Music]
the songs of eon's past tell of battles
between mandalore the great
and an order of sorcerers called jedi
right in this section there's a tuscan
raider riding a bantha
whose mouth hilariously syncs with
mando's audio so that it looks like the
bantha is asking where
where good question bantha this where is
tatooine
that ridge behind them looks a lot like
beggar's canyon former home
to obi-wan kenobi tatooine is likely the
setting we will see
boba fett this season with tamera
morrison set to play the role the final
shot of episode 5 last season showed a
mystery figure on this planet
if you listen closely there the figure
appears to have spurs on their boots
and a subtle beeping sound of their
equipment if you go back and listen to
boba fett carefully in the original
trilogy
his footsteps and empire strikes back
you can hear some spurs
and in an extended scene in the new hope
special edition where george lucas put
boba fett in there his gear
makes that same beeping sound
[Music]
i would just love for some episode this
season maybe the season opener to open
with boba fett blasting and crawling his
way out of the sarlacc just like pat and
oswald dreamed of in parks and rec
the gloved mandalorian armor gauntlet of
boba fett grabs onto the sand outside
the sarlacc pit and then maybe we cut to
an end game
five years later with boba fett glumly
freezing phoenix shannon carbonite and
loading her into slave one oh a boy can
dream then we see the razor crest
swooping down toward this ice planet
with a familiar looking trench as i
suggested in my trailer reaction this
could be ilum
an ice planet that we've seen the
animated series jedi fallen order but
the future planet turned into starkiller
base by the first order in the sequel
trilogy ilum is a location mined for
kyber crystals which are used to power
lightsabers some of you may be arguing
about the timeline because yes
the mandalorian is set in 9 aby after
the battle of yavin whereas
historically the empire had already
started mining this planet 27 years
earlier around
18 bby and when we visit this location
in jedi fallen order that's around 13
bby
the empire has already mostly excavated
it but here in 980y the first order was
still in its early growth stages only a
few years old
not really on the map yet so we could be
looking at an
ilum between phases maybe the empire on
their way out the first order on their
way in to
complete the terraformation into
starkiller base a couple decades later
either way
we could be looking at a link from the
mandalorian to
the origin of the first order and here
and in later shots in the trailer you
can see mando and the child venturing
into this crystal cave maybe to make
contact with the jedi since that
location was so important to the jedi
but before i move on there's another
new world ac port filled with various
quarren just like the aquarium that
mando split with the door in the opening
scene of the series and a few mon
calamari you see one on the far right
there and a couple in the far left
that's the race of admiral ackbar i
would love to explore more of this since
the series pilot referenced the calamari
currency
i can do calamari flan but i can only
pay half
i love that aquatic squishing sound they
mixed in there
hey maybe we'll see mando get a chance
to use these now it's not clear if we're
looking at the planet moncala here
because you know most of their
civilization was under the
ocean i don't know why they would need
above the surface ports and boats like
this
some are saying we might also be looking
at camino or manon from the unites of
the old republic
nina would tie into that camino patch we
saw in the imperial science officer when
he was running those tests on baby yoda
last season
leading many of us to think he might
have been a clone of yoda but
kawel kind of shot down that theory of
biota being genetically engineered
i don't think it was engineered i've
worked in the gene farms
this one looks evolved then again quill
was also a bumpkin our theories don't
have to listen to him
i just love how those people mando's
following one of them has a backpack
filled with water and some aquatic
belongings or pets in there maybe this
is moncala and these travelers are
returning to the undersea part of this
world where they can dive in
and these pups can swim around freely
and yeah it looks like we're gonna have
to watch most of this content going
forward
at home on streaming platforms and i
don't know about you but i don't always
want to keep the subscriptions to these
services in between releases of the
shows and movies i
actually care about the key is to manage
each of those subscriptions by
controlling which credit card you use
for each so that you don't accidentally
get charged for a month that you didn't
want
which is why i use privacy's virtual
burner cards to stay on top of it all
which by the way thanks to privacy for
sponsoring this episode
privacy lets you set up virtual cards
that you can customize and set the
limits of so no
online vendor can charge you more than
the monthly amount that you've set so
for example i've set up an account with
privacy i've linked my bank account i
created a card specifically for my
monthly
disney plus subscription payment so
privacy will ding you with lightning
fast precision if
someone tries to charge this card twice
or if the charge exceeds the amount that
you
set for it and privacy protects your
identity and bank information on the
internet and lets you control the limits
on each virtual card so you can connect
directly to your bank account
with confidence no vendor can overcharge
beyond the limit you've set it's real
simple it's fast just one click privacy
also lets you safely send a burner card
to a friend or family member straight
from your dashboard you can help out
your parents they love getting hacked
head to privacy.com new rockstars and
sign up for an account and it's a
special treat for my viewers
new customers will automatically get
five dollars to spend on your first
purchase for limited time only
folks that is free money and trust me
folks you're gonna use this for
everything
again go to privacy.com new rockstars
and sign up now
on to the next section
you expect me to search the galaxy and
deliver this creature to a race of enemy
sorcerers
this is the way okay so as the armorer's
voice is reminding us of the ancient
wars between the mandalorians and the
jedi
we see this hooded woman while ahsoka
does not appear in this trailer
this is wwe star sasha banks and i
believe she will be playing
sabine wren the mandalorian warrior from
rebels last seen accompanying ahsoka in
that final scene
i think she is going to be the key to
ahsoka and the first step on the
backstory of
how fellow mandalorian bo katan played
by katie sakhoff in this season
lost the darksaber to moff gideon
actually
when banks's character is revealed here
if you listen closely you can
almost hear the faintest sound of the
darksaber
[Music]
now mando's voiceover is asking the
armor about the jedi calling them enemy
sorcerers which is a nice reminder that
to most people in the star wars universe
the jedi are
creepy wizards who pressure farmers into
giving up their kids indoctrinating them
into a dark cult
a cult that sparked the galactic civil
war in most people's eyes such
skepticism was echoed in the original
film both by smugglers and
imperial officers pokey religions and
ancient weapons are no match for a good
blaster at your side
don't try to fragment us with your
sorcerer's ways lord vader
your sad devotion to that ancient
religion has not helped you conjure up
the stolen data tapes
or given you clairvoyance enough to find
the rebels hidden fort
but i do love how after maybe sabine
harry osborne's out of there
baby oda looks up at mando with a little
quiver of its nose and lips
as if smelling something familiar about
this being
or maybe smelling something sticky about
those mon calamari i mean it is a
sea port it won't usually smell too good
next
okay i gotta say i love seeing a
freaking boat in star wars now yes we
have seen boats before like
naboo and the prequels or that
amphibious invasion and kashyyyk
i just think it's rare and refreshing to
see a sea voyage out on open waters
the attention to detail is pretty great
that quaran behind mando is wearing
waders like a deep-sea fisherman he may
have a squid face but he don't want his
socks to get wet then the razor crest is
flanked by
new republic x-wings foil's going into
attack position i'm thinking this could
be the new republic gold squadron could
be trying to take him down or maybe
providing cover as escorts after
x-wing's brief appearance last season
i would just love to see more of the new
republic fleet in action during this era
before
you know they all get swiftly wiped out
and force awakens like it's nothing
then a quick shot of cara dune and carol
weathers as grief karga on navarro both
of them have
cleaned up grief might have even taken
over as mayor of this town some of that
color
seems to have been brought into the
town's overhangs things are looking good
for now
moving on
you know this is no place for a child
wherever i go he goes here imperial tie
fighters
unfold and launch and then we hear that
familiar
of the imperial navy alert blaring over
stormtroopers running through these
bulkheads now giancarlo esposito hinted
that moff gideon would be commanding a
much
bigger ship this season making me think
that this might be a new
class of star destroyer some scout
troopers swoop down into this canyon on
speeder bikes but
look where they're coming from there are
a few scattered incapacitated
stormtroopers on this platform
suggesting to me that mando or maybe
some of his forces attacked this
imperial facility or maybe escaped it by
fighting their way out and now are now
being pursued but at the base of this
canyon looks like a
thin lava river you can also see it when
mando jet packs down into this canyon
that poor trooper has to use his foot to
slow the turn but he has to wait to do
it until after
passing over the lava river now sure
there may be a lot of planets with lava
rivers in this universe when i'm
thinking we're looking at mustafar
home to the late darth vader sith castle
but you know must be further down from
the big lava rivers and lakes that we've
seen before
we did see another part of mustafar in
the rise of skywalker remember the
burning forests of kylo's opening scene
and then mando strings up that lurker on
the lamppost he shoots out the light to
leave the guy in darkness but that flash
though exposes more of that graffiti
kind of hard to make out most of it
though you can kind of see a
stormtrooper helmet and a face that
looks like
c-3po what is this raiders of the lost
ark moving on
so i've heard
okay so mando enters this fighting arena
with two gamoreans hitting each other
with these axes the flags and banners
hanging overhead don't appear to match
any of the flags i could find for star
wars planets but as we saw with the
flags of the pod races on tatooine these
could just be the chosen heraldry for
past victors in this fighting ring
mike wazowski here is reportedly named
gor
koresh this guy is an abyssin one of
those showed up at the moseleisly
cantina if koresh is his name
i do find it interesting that they chose
the last name of the branch dominion
cult leader david koresh
either way this guy is clearly bad news
based on the voice he sounds a lot like
john favreau who also voiced the heavy
infantry paz visla in season one baby
oda sees mando charging up his whistling
bird gauntlet
and noops back into his egg perhaps
remembering when mando used it to save
him in season one
[Music]
on to the final clip
this is the way
i love it by cutting the black the
editing leaves us with a blind
soundscape of mando's beatdown the same
way baby yoda is experiencing this from
inside his shell
based on the sound effects after that
initial whistling bird deployment most
of the hits are metallic pings
telling me that if any of these
attackers were able to dodge a bird they
still had to face mando's best scar
armor and the fight ends with mando
tossing a vibro blade into this
zabrak that's the horned bipeds of
dathomir the same race as darth maul
this guy has tattoos just like maul does
i remember carrie dude also dueled a
zabrak last season
and then mando says this is the way
which at first sounds like a bit of a
weird time to echo the whole mandalorian
creed but if you think about it he might
just be using it practically in this
moment
telling baby yoda this is the way as in
this way
let's go just a little way of showing
how mandalorian rituals aren't
abstract or archaic they're functional
and survival based and one last detail
before we wrap up over that disney plus
title card bjornsen mixes in
the mandalorian theme with the notes of
the flute
[Music]
ah now this teaser was obviously just a
taste of what's to come in season two
focusing mostly on the relationship that
drew us into the series
mando and the child with all the
questions about asokatano bocaton
mafkitian in the dark saber boba fett
the new characters played by timothy
olafan michael bean
all likely to be explored in a future
trailer season one did give us two
trailers before episodes came out so i
wouldn't be surprised to see another
trailer next month that goes into more
of the plot but you can join this
discussion on new rockstar's official
discord server which we offer to patrons
of new rockstars at any tier even a
dollar a month just go to
patreon.comrockstars subscribe to new
rockstars and hit that notification bell
follow me on instagram eavos follow new
rockstars thanks for watching
i have spoken
[Music]
you